what's going ok why we gonna ring with
the square root of 81 what what's the
square root of 81 I don't know guys
obviously known each other for a long
time and you're hilarious and you're
incredible actors so I was wondering if
you guys would impersonate each other
impersonate each other I might have a
good 70 headers right now I bad I know I
got two of them one is a okay you ready
there we go
listen okay she ready she ready yes
[Music]
would say hmm what yes currently right
now you know sales are out of this world
on ticket sales for my shows are quite
amazing right now no I was gonna drop
her album but I figured I don't want to
take nothing away from jay-z yeah like
this I'm the most amazing human being
alive right now
why would I do that I want to give other
people a chance to shine as if I care
but people's egos how do you feel I'm
just enthralled with how wonderful she
is betraying me
it's almost dead on someone did you guys
always so good
you can get on my way [ __ ] I love this
movie you guys it's so hilarious it's so
heartwarming thank you so much welcome
this movie is about second chances so I
was wondering if you could share with me
a moment in your life where you felt
like you got a second chance oh wow
you know I think that I look at that
question little bit differently I have
been very very fortunate and blessed in
my life I think that I am constantly
being given second chances by God
because I'm constantly making small
mistakes in my life and things that I
still have an opportunity to they don't
hold me back I still have a chance to to
overcome you know whatever those
mistakes have been I haven't like had
like the big huge moment of failure or
something that I did you know that I
needed a big huge second chance for yet
maybe it's coming but I just think that
in every day of my life
I am constantly doing things that I
could have done better and God has
allowed me to continue to be successful
yeah I would say just like just talking
about career like probably like doing
the second best man was like a great
second chance for me you know because
like you know I had done a couple movies
that you know that weren't that you know
banging at the box office let's say and
so you know and then and there was a
whole like you know thought process that
like well these kinds of movies aren't
you know profitable anymore so like
we're not gonna make them but you know
thanks to a couple movies like Think
Like a Man and a jumping the broom it
was like okay we saw an opportunity to
reignite a franchise and it really was
good for me well I can't wait for
everyone to see this movie I feel like
this will be like 13 people need it you
know they want to laugh escapism get
away from you know the news
[Music]
[Music]